um let's talk about Meg's it's so after
Prince Harry and Megan Markel ducked out
of their royal responsibilities the
family declared they'll be stripped of
their royal title fair trade off Ron no
no you guys stay in the royal family
it's just I wouldn't if I get in the
royal family you couldn't kick me out
just not having a word being famous just
because of my last name that's the
treatment only a Kardashian get they're
stepping on the Kardashians of being
famous for doing nothing the Kardashians
are mad they don't want him here I heard
Harry wants to be known as the artists
artist formerly known as Prince what do
you think I heard that Harry is asking
people in Canada to just call him Harry
like this is a novelty sorry hi fine key
ah hi my name's Harry I don't want to be
called Prince just Harry that was that
was very good yeah I just thought that
going by your first name is like a big
deal oh yeah yeah
it's just making it known if you know
I'm like a Beyonce write about where one
name yeah on that sense but I don't
really just care yeah yeah let him live
their lives just like cool if you want
to be Prince cool you know I'm a
princess of Texas so yeah
I feel like she did you know she gets
swept off her feet like the dream she
goes over to England and she has this
crazy wedding and she's literally
royalty but then it gets a little
mundane and then she's like alright
let's head back to LA I'm gonna go to my
cold reading class on Pico again and
just get back into acting so I think the
fun part was over and now she's sort of
got Laborde but you're like it's not
that easy you don't just get to get out
of it now so I think it's odd that they
let him scram uh-huh yeah I have some
hot takes this house is a thousand years
old I don't know how to renovate it
yeah it's a local a Malibu what are we
doing like if people don't want to be
somewhere okay cool bike like and then
you start your life I'm just kind of
like whatever subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going